welcome back I'll have you know this
entire episode will be removed and never
shown because of this caller which is
driving me crazy
[Laughter]
is the left getting guidelines from
Babylon B punch lines conservative
parody cite the Babylon B is apparently
so good at what it does nearly 100 joke
headlines have actually come true CEO
Seth Dillon told Fox News digital the
problem isn't that their site is too
close to reality it's that reality is
too close to satire
here are some examples in September 2020
the B wrote BLM rioters awarded Nobel
Peace Prize and then February 20 21st
black lives matter nominated for Nobel
Peace Prize wow that's pretty good in
June 2021 the B writes Progressive
Church announces new drag queen Bible
story hour and then in December 21 what
happens Lutheran Church hosts drag queen
prayer time for children nothing like
having prayer with drag queens totally
improves it
and May 17th they uh the B wrote two
plus two equals four insists
close-minded bigot and then in December
2021 USA Today writes is math racist
November 2021 Babylon B Playschool
unveils vaccinate Me Elmo and then in
June 2022 Elmo is now vaccinated for
covet 19.
still waiting for the episode where Elmo
dies suddenly
but I don't is that a bad taste
I tastes cause it's about Elmo
they love him a little too much okay
September 2022 in the bee that he's
wrote nine reasons not to worry about
the tanking economy and just a couple of
weeks later in the Washington Post seven
ways a recession could be good for you
financially
it's true you don't see many fat people
in poor countries
silence
I knew that I could have taken it out
but I said you know what I'm going to
leave it in in May 2022 Babylon B wrote
Mattel unveils Mattel yeah Mattel
unveils new pregnant Ken doll then two
weeks later Mattel's first transgender
Barbie doll designed after Laverne Cox
gotta hand it to Cox
so
[Applause]
what you people are so sick so sick you
just let a clever choke lie flat and
then an off the cuff dirty joke they
applaud right in I I think I have to
start thinking more disgustingly all
right so today's punch lines turn out to
be tomorrow's headlines which caused me
to write this jokey headline Brian
Kilmeade crushed by Falling meteor
no one shows up to his funeral because
they're out partying with the king of
late night Greg Gutfeld
uh Jimmy I'll be happy if only half of
that is right
help me out I know I don't go out yeah
that's why only half of it will be right
yeah tell me it's dead Gutfeld orders
more Chinese spare ribs yeah exactly by
the way that is what I'm ordering after
the show we love you for it well what is
the most surprising thing about the
Babylon bee I will tell it to you really
quick two things first of all I'd love
to be as you know let's not act like
they're the only comedy site to get
headlines right CNN has gotten 14 of
them right this year alone which isn't
nothing hey girl
um the actual impressive thing is not
that they're right it's that they're
still funny in an age where the news is
already inherently funny like we're
living in real satire yesterday you
alluded to Leah Thomas ESPN honored her
as one of its women of the Year
yesterday a male swimmer like that's
already kind of goofy when ESPN is like
she's so brave for getting in that water
like the only thing she was facing was
shrinkage yeah you know what I mean
[Applause]
but so the fact that they can continue
to consistently be funny where the
headlines are already so warped is
probably more impressive than anything I
would say you know what I find
impressive cat it's a Christian website
and I think there's a stereotype that
Christians can't be funny correct and I
think they have destroyed that
stereotype right before our eyes what
say you lady in blue
yeah I definitely think that it's funny
I did their podcast and like the whole
end of it was about religious stuff and
I did my best yeah they did the same
thing but we had a good conversation
actually it wasn't like they were mean
to me about it um I think that um I
actually write my book about satire and
how studies show that it can make people
more politically engaged and
um the only problem with it is sometimes
people can't decide what's or decipher
true from what satire but that's because
a lot of the political leaders do things
that are so unbelievable so that's
actually an argument for satirizing them
more often because it actually makes
people more skeptical of the narratives
they see from politics in the media
which we all should be doing more often
to hold these people accountable very
good young lady I do have a copy of your
book here I read it over the weekend it
was quite delightful thank you yes we'll
talk about it later in the show if we
have time
sitting here quietly we might run out of
time oh we don't have time for cat's
book
I sleep at night
friends I yeah how do I sleep at night
I have problems right now Harris it's
with this caller and it's completely
driving me crazy no one can see this
problem but you no it's true all right
I'll stop oh right Harris
um now he's mad you know I'm not mad I
never get mad trust me trust me uh do
you follow the B uh yeah what do you
make of it what do you make of the story
you know I do so much hard news that it
is really intriguing sometimes to watch
like that TV show back in the day I
don't remember the name of it but it
would tell the headlines before they
actually happen and so to see something
like that come to life is really
interesting to me because we're always
trying to like okay what's the next
headline what's the next thing so we can
get everything all ready and we don't we
just do breaking news I will say this
there's one in particular story when
they were talking about Kamala Harris
and her likability problems and how she
might go to Hillary Clinton to solve
them and then like a month later the
headline was
Harris vice president seeking help on
likability from Hillary Clinton yes and
I thought we should have had a lower
third breaking news for that yeah we
could have been ready had we believed in
the Babylon bee with all our heart which
by the way going to Hillary for help
with likability is like going to bill
for help with office etiquette yeah oh
you were so gentle right then yeah you
could have said a lot I didn't work
clean I'm opening for Jamie in this
block yeah you could have said a lot
with that yeah you got it back I thought
it was about like getting a stain out of
a dress Jamie has a comedian he probably
heard that the old phrase comedy is
tragedy plus time is that how you
describe your life
yeah yeah that's so funny my dad used to
say your life is tragedy plus tragedy
um and time no I'm just kidding I'm I'm
Blown Away by um I also love to be
ridiculous Geniuses over at the B I
think that trans the cat the doll thing
yeah there's like a bar a trans I don't
think we need our Barbies like helping
reflect what Ken's been walking around
without a penis for 20 years yeah
it's true right and we argue about like
if Barbie's the red my favorite B-Line
uh headline ever was do you guys
remember they said to prove you're
vaccinated you had to show proof of a
positive covid test yeah
I got it that was it hurts your brain I
think that was one of the funniest yeah
yeah but I'm with you that I like I like
how you did um Seth came to one of Rob
Schneider shows once when I was
backstage and I was listening to him
talking he's like super smart guy
whatever and I was thinking like man
these headlines are coming true I should
try to get one and I was just I was
trying to talk him into doing one uh
comedian has threesome ah and um
a little bit out of nowhere did you see
the one they did one that said um
that people were getting stuck on it you
know those capture things where it's yes
every time they did one that said like
people were having trouble because it
said click which one is a woman they
didn't know what's about I just had this
happen I tried to play do you remember
the game Guess Who yeah I don't even
remember that it's like all the
different little pictures and then your
opposite and I was playing against uh my
kid eight years old and one of their
friends and you can't play Guess Who
anymore well I can't it's the same kind
of thing because they go I go like hey
is it like is is the person could you
pick one and you try to narrow it down
from all the little characters and I'm
like oh you know I go oh is yours you
know dark skinned and they go hey you
can't that's racist and I'm like no I'm
trying to figure out and they get the
little kid goes I don't see color and I
was like we're never going to let you
drive a car then
[Laughter]
sometimes your jokes are like a four
hour drive to 10 minutes at the beach my
jokes are like you get your towel and
your sunscreen you get from the beach is
closed
[Laughter]
all right we gotta get out of here
before he starts cutting himself hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else